hello everyone i'm kristen tomlin the
founder and ceo of dough cookie dough
confections and trust me i know
a thing or two about baking the perfect
cookies and welcome to pro tips from pro
chefs
i'm gonna show you all of my tips and
tricks on making sure that your cookies
turn out beautiful
and perfect and delicious every single
time first thing you're gonna need is
just a baking sheet
i like one that happens to have a rim on
it so that it's easy to grab
from the oven and any time i'm baking i
always line the sheet with parchment
paper you can find it pre-cut
in these sheets which is the way to go
because it already will fit your pan
perfectly
and you won't have to worry about
getting any cuts on that blade you also
are going to need
a cookie scoop and this is just to make
sure that all of your cookies are the
same size when baking
that way they'll spread evenly they'll
bake evenly and they'll all
look amazing so go ahead fill your
cookie scoop all the way to the top
and just when you put it on the sheet
leave a little bit of room
i usually say three fingers between each
cookie to make sure that there's enough
room for it to spread nicely
i always like to add whatever inclusions
are inside my cookies
on top to make it extra beautiful and
make sure that all those yummy mix-ins
don't fall down to the bottom
and now we're ready for the oven but
you're gonna have to make sure your oven
is fully preheated
before we stick our cookies in so mine's
already
very hot and ready to go so let's go
ahead and put it in
so halfway through baking you're going
to want to check on your cookies make
sure that everything is baking evenly
usually i like to rotate the pan and if
i have two trays
i just swap the top one with the bottom
one i can tell my cookies are just about
done because my kitchen smells delicious
and last time i peeked they're golden
brown on the outside
you're going to want to grab them and
just let them cool on the baking sheet
resist the urge to dig
in just yet let them cool here for about
five minutes but luckily because we have
this parchment paper on here
cleanup is gonna be a breeze and your
bottoms will never
ever get brown for more recipes and tips
go to thedrewberrymoreshow.com
and grab a copy of my cookbook hello
cookie dough
for lots of other recipes and tips just
like this
[Music]
huh